لاشو، البالغة من العمر n عامًا فقط، هي واحدة من
أصغر الفلسطينيين الذين يقدمون تقارير عن
واقع الحياة تحت الحصار في غزة
بعد أن شنت إسرائيل
ردها العسكري على هجوم هام في 7 أكتوبر/تشرين الأول،
واضطرت لاما وعائلتها إلى الفرار من منزلهم في
مدينة غزة بسبب الغارات الجوية الإسرائيلية.  لقد
هربوا مرة إلى وحدة السيارات في الجنوب
ومرة ​​أخرى إلى ملجأ، وقد جمعت رافا
مئات الآلاف من
المتابعين عبر الإنترنت لتقاريرها عن
التحديات اليومية المتمثلة في عيش الحرب الحرة
والتي تشاركها على موقع Instagram الخاص بها بدءًا
من إجراء مقابلات مع الأطفال المصابين
بسبب قصف المستشفيات وحتى التوثيق.
الظروف المعيشية الصعبة في
الملاجئ المدرسية "إل" هي صوت لبعض أطفال
غزة الأكثر نشاطًا،
وقال والد "إل" لشبكة "سي إن إن" إنه
فخور للغاية، مضيفًا أننا نعاني
من الحرب مثل الأشخاص الآخرين في غزة،
ورسالتها واضحة للعالم أجمع.
يرجى وقف الحرب والعودة إلى
الحياة الطبيعية. الأرقام الرسمية
من داخل قطاع غزة والتي لا يمكن
التحقق منها بشكل مستقل من قبل شبكة سي إن إن تشير
إلى أن الأطفال يمثلون 8000 من
المدنيين الذين قتلوا منذ 7 أكتوبر، أي
ثلث إجمالي القتلى على الرغم من الحرب.
ظروف خطيرة تواصل لمى بشجاعة
تقديم التقارير للعالم
وبث الأمل في جيل جديد